hello and welcome to my video series of
mall bioexplained in three minutes where
i explain the concept of mall biology
less than three minutes or so if you
haven't yet subscribed hit that
subscribe button
in today's installment we'll talk about
nested pcr
so nested pcr is a modification of
normal pcr reaction
that was designed to improve the
sensitivity and specificity of this
reaction
nested pcr involves the usage of two set
of primers
instead of one in a two successive
pcr reaction and these kind of
modification
helps to improve the specificity and
sensitivity
so in this video we would understand the
mechanism behind nested pcr so stay
tuned till the end
now in any pcr reaction
we need to ah we need to have a master
mix
and there would be template we mix it
together in a pcr tube and then start
right so we would start the same
procedure for the nested pcr as well
we'll take the template
put it in a pcr tube then we'll take the
master mix
and put it in this pcr tube so this
master mix
generally has primer pairs forward and
reverse primer
pairs then check polymer is dntp buffer
and mgcl2
but in this particular nested pcr
reaction
there are two primer sets right that
means
in total there would be two forward
primers and two reverse primers
and that has something to do with the
specificity let me explain how
so let's put these nested pcr
reaction in the thermal cycle and try to
understand this process
in a general pci reaction there would be
first step which is denaturation where
you have
separation of the dna strands then there
would be primary angling
then there would be extension of that
which would lead to amplification
but along with these specific amplicons
the problem in pcr reaction is sometimes
you might get
non-specific amplification like shown
here
with these specific amplicons there are
non-specific amplicons as well
and in order to avoid non-specific
amplicons
one way we can go about the situation is
to do a nested pcr
nested pcr has two sets of primers that
i have mentioned earlier
so this green set of primers would
amplify a region which is slightly
more than the region of interest but
this
red set of primers would be dedicated
for the
region of interest so first this green
set of primers would act
and let's say it would amplify the
region shown
here by chance if these green primers
also amplify
a non-specific product that can be
uh that can be negative
in the next round how
this red set of primers would answer the
question so the red set of primers would
be specific to our region of interest
so these red primers would not hybridize
with this non-specific amplicon as a
result in the next set of pcr reaction
these non-specific amplicon would not be
amplified
and would not come would not
contaminate our amplicon as a result
we'll get
specific amplification and that's the
prince principle
behind nested pcr and it is one of the
widely used technique in molecular
biology labs to get specific
amplification
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
enjoyed this video
give it a quick thumbs up and don't
forget to like share and subscribe you
can support me in patreon or you can use
your bim upi app to
support my channel and you can also take
my academic course which is available in
an academy app
and don't forget to like share and
subscribe thank you